meine damen und herren david haye tod
ist habe sie sie ist nicht tot die hat
nur alle ihre beiträge auf instagram
gelöscht habe sie allerdings durch diese
instagram videos so berühmt wurde hat
sie durch das ganze löschen dieser
ganzen beiträge fotos videos nun ihre
karriere mehr oder weniger beendet ich
habe ja schon mal auf dieses kleine
mädchen hier reagiert die gerne mal auf
teuren autos mit einer menge geld
passiert doch nun habe ich mir gedacht
freunde
es gibt ja nicht nur da draußen die ein
reiches verwöhntes kind ist sondern es
gibt auch viele andere rich kids auf
instagram von instant
ich kann kotzen ich meine freunde schaut
euch das einfach mal an das sind
ich habe das euro sind ich glaube er
nicht dass in euros kein gelben scheint
wirklich im ausland 200 ich glaube das
sind euros das links sind dann auf jeden
fall die 50er dann kommen die 100 einen
grünen dann die 201 gelben dann die 500
teil in lila das heißt es sind iso um
die ah ich würd sagen um die 20.000 euro
die
eher einfachen sonder tasche mit sich
herumträgt und dann einfach diese eklige
capture one knows you're dead money for
the weekend alter man weiß natürlich nie
auf solche sachen jetzt irgendwie
gefällt sind oder ob das einfach nur
irgendwo von irgendwem oder ab dass
vielleicht jemand ist einfach in der
bank arbeitet aber falls das mein kind
wäre und ich würde mitbekommen wie mein
kind okay wenn das mein kind wäre dann
wäre ich glaube ich als vater auch ein
bisschen bescheuert weil ich im 20.000
euro einfach so ein jahren drücken würde
aber ich würde dich instant auf der
familie rausschmeißen was ist ucc für
ein arrogantes stimmt aber wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten bild de die let
me down today
also auf deutsch übersetzt mein vater
hat mich im stich gelassen er hat mir
nicht so viel geld gegeben wie
vielleicht sonst immer sondern nur
irgendwie 200 pfund und eine uhr oder
schreibt dieser user halt noch dazu
today dh das hat er für einen tag
bekommen wenn mir jemand einfach jeden
tag ohne dass ich etwas dafür tun müsste
200 euro geben würde alter ich wäre der
glücklichste mensch der welt und er sagt
eddy hat ihn im stich gelassen ran out
of paper vor präparation und dann
benutzt diese person ihr macbook um da
was drauf zu schreiben wie zu beginn
bereits gesagt man kann natürlich nie
sagen hey ist das jetzt wirklich
irgendwie echt oder hat das wirklich
irgendjemand so irgendwie gemacht oder
es ist wirklich so rich hat aber wenn
das jemand getan haben sollte dann hast
du überhaupt keinen sinn für materielle
güter which one for you today finde ich
gar nichts zu sagen die sache ist man
denkt okay da stehen jetzt zwei geile
karren irgendwie die kosten vielleicht
zusammen so locker 300 400.000 euro m
das ist schon schlimm wenn dann hinkend
ins switch paar also welches auto nehme
ich heute auf dem weg zur schule doch
dann habe ich im internet dieses bild
gefunden
back to school mit diesem preis
also
das
mir fällt nichts mehr ein nice to be
home to the mummy den finde ich ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht mehr so schlimm das ist
einfach nur irgendein krasses haus
irgendwie im hintergrund und erst in
einem normalen auto oder ist es alles
auto ich glaube das war irgendwie soll
suv range rover da irgendwie sowas und
er fährt hat nach hause also einfach hey
ich weiß dass ich zu hause bin um mara
zu sehen aber trotzdem halt so loki
fleck sing my sister türk mapping
helikopter
dieser moment wenn sich deine schwester
einfach deinen helikopter schnappt er
kennt mich als nächstes haben wir eine
person die wirkliche ultra krass angibt
um das so richtig ekelhaft also er
schreibt went to beim wird also erst
losgegangen und einzukaufen came home wo
es bis also einen goldenen champagner
eine was ist das für eine uhr ich kenne
mich nicht so krass aus mit uhren aber
irgend eine krasse uhr dann dieser
heftige koffer neben diese
champagnerflasche drin ist
wenn jetzt auch mal so immer wenn ich im
supermarkt und milch einkaufen will dann
kaufen wir auch meine neue urlaubsgäste
new labour ist mit seinem lamborghini
cabrio gefahren dann hat es ein wenig
angefangen zu regnen und er sagt er
braucht einen neuen lamborghini
ich glaube du brauchst einfach nur ein
drittel deine fresse rich color today
bei dem bild finde ich sagen man ganz
klar dass das irgendwie nur jemand war
der das normal fotografiert hat oder
sogar rechts daneben hat auch noch ein
gt3 steht von porsche da hinten steht
noch ein r8 ich denke also eher dass das
irgendjemand aus dem auto treffen
fotografiert hat und dass kinder langsam
zu ende oder so bei manchen sachen sieht
man auch schon sehr toll dass es
irgendwie fake ist aber bei einigen
sachen denkt man sich halt irgendwie
oder das kann eigentlich nur fake sein
aber wenn diese leute wirklich das ernst
meinen was war das denn bedeuten diese
leute das wirklich ernst meinen in dem
moment und dann irgendwie sagen hey
meine schwester hat meinen linken
helikopter mitgenommen und gerade so was
will ich ein lied hey sogar zutrauen
dann ist das echt droht es ekelhaft
solche leute wie ihr werdet nie freunde
finden in euren ganzen leben crash der
aston driving ist und dann ein foto von
dem lenkrad eines bentley und ein
wütender smiley
die sache ist halt leider ein kollege
von mir ist so lange zeit in england zur
schule gegangen und hat mir da auch
immer stories erzählt von diesen tritt
englisches komischen mädels und so und
da war halt auch irgend so ein typ dabei
der den m2 irgendwie gecrasht hat in
ging song irgendwo im wald oder so gegen
baum gefahren hat und er hat seine zwei
wochen später direkten 9 m2 und da denke
ich mir ganz einfach was ist erziehungs
technisch bei den eltern schief gelaufen
bezüglich erziehung möchte ich ihnen
einmal ganz kurz was sagen und zwar
erreicht der ja bei den jockeys ex
topmodel finale bin ich war doch auch
auf der aftershow party und habe mich
dort mit der mutter eines von mir
unterhalten und habe mich mit ihr sehr
sehr lange tatsächlich über erziehung
unterhalten und sie hat mir echte krasse
ratschläge gegeben was man kindern
wirklich erlauben sollte und was nicht
und da denke ich mir halt einfach wenn
ich der vater wäre von einem jungen der
seinen m2 gegen einen baum fährt dann
würde ich sagen hey du fährst jetzt
erstmal drei jahre lang mit einem
fucking alten vw golf
damit diese person materielle werte mehr
schätzen lernt also ich finde man sollte
sich wirklich sehr sehr krass gedanken
machen wie man seine kinder erzieht aber
wenn ich dann halt so was ihr esst im
driving bis da denke ich mir einfach nur
doof plates
meine standard
aktion ist wirklich einfach dass ich
hier sitze mit der hand in meinem
gesicht aber was man den leuten gut
heißen muss sie essen pizza zwar auf
einem ipad aber es ist pizza also von 1
ganz okay ready set one for the past ich
weiß nicht genau was mit passt in diesem
zusammenhang gemeint ist ich glaube mal
dass diese person man eine klausur
besteht und bei mir war es zum beispiel
mal so wenn ich irgendwie in gute noten
hatte oder so dann hat meine mutter mir
mein lieblingsessen gekocht nicht
durften wie im videospiel mir kaufen
oder irgendwie sowas einfach so kleine
anreize setzen oder beispielsweise als
ich zur uni gegangen bin habe ich mich
damit immer belohnt dass wenn ich es
geschafft habe quasi eine halbe stunde
am stück durch zu lernen und mich
ablenken zu lassen das dann eine runde
fifa spielen konnte und hier bekommt die
person sieben neue uhren ich denke mir
ehrlich gesagt nicht dass das ganze
nächte sondern dass wir einfach
irgendwelche leute ein spaß erlaubt
haben aber teils echt wäre würde ich
gerne ins gehirn scheißen finally home
freunde
es ist ja schon schlimm genug dass diese
person mit ihm wie dem haus angibt und
dem auto vor der tür im helikopter da
oben aber finally
dk
finally wahrscheinlich gegen so ein 16
jähriger junge der nicht mal irgendwie
richtig englisch kann und dann halt
hauptsache angeben mit irgendwelchen
gütern von den eltern das finde ich halt
g so krass ekelhaft in diesem video
mache ich halt auch voll viele talk
eigentlich so über meine meinungen ich
finde dass so etwas ekelhaft das habe
ich schon vor einem jahr mal in nem
instagram post in die caption
geschrieben ich finde es echt okay wenn
leute irgendwie eine geile wohnung haben
oder ein geiles auto oder von mir aus
nie yacht oder einen chat oder was weiß
ich wenn diese personen allerdings
unglaublich krass damit prahlen und vor
anderen leuten damit unfassbar krass
angeben find ich das einfach nur todes
ekelhaft es ist für mich das schlimmste
was menschen machen können du drückst
quasi anderen leuten unter die nase hält
huck was ich für geile güter besitzer
hey schau dir das an das macht dich
nicht zu einem besseren menschen
da die youtuber machen das halt relativ
krass also wenn man sich da
beispielsweise einen jackpot cook der da
immer irgendwie seine villa film zu der
sie sich diese ganzen luxus
kartenverkauf das ist schon sehr sehr
egeler finde ich natürlich muss man dann
auch sagen dass jack poole halt jeden
tag sein alltag filmt und irgendwie ja
auch manchmal mit autos irgendwo
hinfahren muss dann muss er halt
zwangsläufig irgendwie film aber ich
denke halt einfach nur so wenn leute
jeden tag bilder vor ihrer karre
hochladen oder irgendwie das logo oder
dass die marke oder in ihre uhr da wird
lässt sich so ekelhaft immer zeigen und
sagen hey guck mal hier meine watch
kommt man hier mein auto das ist echt
nicht so cool finde ich es wollte pocket
manigat dann will ich ehrlich gesagt gar
nichts mehr zu sagen es ist einfach eine
person die als taschengeld irgendwo
30.000 euro bekommen hat mich menschlich
gesehen ziemlich abstoßen what a great
time und dann samuel obendrauf
wow
falls sie nicht kennen sondern normale 1
liter flasche davon koste 40 50 euro
die rolex ein bild zur flasche ich weiß
nicht was das für eine rolex ist ich
habe mich mit unrecht nicht sonderlich
gut aus aber das foto ist halt auf jeden
fall fähig aber trotzdem so eine
ekelhafte catchen darunter zu schreiben
kommen wir nun allerdings zum letzten
foto was ich heute vorbereitet habe das
ist meiner meinung nach ein foto wo man
wirklich sehen kann wow das ist einfach
nur genervt der die will have to bei mir
in aragon einerseits sieht man im
hintergrund irgendwelche geilen will
dann sieht man im vordergrund und
künstlich angelegten see und dann liegt
ein golf cart in diesem künstlich
angelegten see also golf ist ja eh gegen
die sonne reichen sport irgendwie
geworden und ich war ich
ich will dass die ganze zeit erklären
aber ich denke einfach nur am liebsten
würde ich mir die ganze zeit geben wird
im gesicht wenn ich diese ganzen bitte
an der stelle wird das heutige video ist
allerdings auch band meine damen und
herren ich war einfach auf ein paar
webseiten und halbwegs wo diese rich
schaufenster kremmen snapshot
vorgestellt wurden und ich habe auf
jeder seite mindestens vier mal kotzen
müssen falls ich meine reaktion auf
diese widget beiträge gefallen haben das
gerne mal einen like da soll ich
eventuell nochmal auf solche ripke
beiträge reagieren auf irgendwelche
bilder von apps davon weil es gibt so
ich habe mein mikro geschlagen es gibt
halt wirklich unfassbar viele fotos
davon erlassen like das schaffen wir
60.000 likes dann habe ich auf jeden
fall bock das sommer zu machen und sehe
dass ihr daran auch irgendwie interesse
habt 60.000 likes freunde schreibt man
die kommentare rich fit wenn ihr auch
alle leute da wenn ihr am liebsten ich
will eigentlich eben eine backpfeife
geben alter